seeking secrets is a social experiment
where strangers share honest and complex
truths we ask that you treat the
participants with respect
thank you for listening to their
stories my ex-boyfriend said he would
kill himself if he wasn't with me i call
him my ex because he's gone
i've been feeling grief for two months
now
[Music]
you died
later
she died
[Music]
i've lost loved ones and i've also had
friends who have struggled
significantly with grief but
i can never tell those friends that
i'm often very suicidal i maintain this
sunny disposition to hide what i've been
going through but
as they're coping with loss i'm coping
with the effects that
losing my own life might have on their
life
oh no
[Laughter]
i sit in the same position as her every
single day my mom who has done the most
for me i feel like i can't even tell her
how i feel sometimes because the times
where it's gotten really really bad
seeing her
feel like she's going to lose me has
hurt me
so bad
sometimes putting on a sunny disposition
is
trying to protect other people and
sometimes it's also trying not to
address
maybe what's going on with me
and so you use it as like a hiding
mechanism for yourself as well as for
other people
and it is
a dangerous thing to feel kind of that
alone
i'd highly encourage this person that
they might be surprised if they share
how they're feeling with their friends
when i was like 12 years old
me and my two brothers were
told that my grandfather had passed away
of a heart attack
it was really sad first like death i had
to go through and then fast forward like
two years later maybe more than that i'm
snooping through my mom's phone
and i find her reddit account
and on her reddit account she detailed
how my grandfather
actually committed suicide
they just told me he had a heart attack
because they didn't want to explain the
concept of suicide to me
he had died two years ago but now i'm
breathing all over again and for
something completely different
and i can't tell my family it must
really hurt because
they said they can't tell other people
or tell their family like it hurts that
they can't
mourn in the way they usually do
i would understand why she wouldn't want
to like tell her children how he
actually did it because i know that
suicide is a very hard
topic to discuss
i can't imagine being an adult trying to
explain really big topics to kid you
know because
what i would i don't even i don't know
what i would do the first overdose you
know first death in my life
i wasn't told what
actually happened i actually was also
told it was a heart attack it's almost
like you have to solve a puzzle before
you can grieve when it comes to that
kind of stuff especially when you're
younger for this specific person they
didn't
keep
that information from you to hurt you it
was to actually protect you
so i've grown up in the bible about my
entire life
and earlier this year my cousin died by
suicide previous to this i removed
myself from religion it's probably been
about a year now when the time came for
the funeral
all people could keep saying and talking
about was thank goodness he was saved
two months before he died
and i kept repeating it over
and over and over again and in those
moments i was so angry
because i know that there were people
there at his funeral who thought that he
probably went to hell
it's very unfortunate
at a time like a funeral
for people to
discuss
things like that but that may just be
their way of coping suicide is a very
hard thing to conceptualize especially
when it's your loved ones so
relying on faith is definitely something
that
is an anchor for a lot of people to get
through stuff like this after i lost my
sister the judgment that i just saw
from the church when i wasn't actively
going back after the loss i just
oh man i relate to that so well
my 15 year old uh
brother
took his own life three years ago
every day i struggle with forgiving him
because it seemed like a very selfish
and weak thing to do
my dad took his own life two days uh
before my 10th birthday
and
you know it kind of it ripped the family
apart pretty significantly i remember i
had woken up uh the night that he had
passed
and i had uh
i dialed his number i was like i just
want to talk to him so bad you know and
i and then i never did
and for the longest time you know i was
like that would have made all the
difference
i find that i'm angriest in
moments of transition so like graduating
from high school or
you know getting a new job
moments where it's like i wish i wish he
was here to see
what i'm doing maybe it's too easy to
say we all make mistakes because that's
a pretty big mistake
i i hope he can forgive his brother and
more than forgive is accept his
suffering and the choice he made and
you know life's different for everybody
and i think
acceptance is like the right path
towards peace
my ex-boyfriend said he would kill
himself if he wasn't with me
i call him my ex because he's gone i've
been feeling grief for two months now
someone very close to me when i was
younger
was
suffering with depression and was very
suicidal and i was
really the only person that knew
what they were going through i had went
home and told my mom
um because this time it was real
i never talked to her after that i was
receiving messages from my friend
about how much she hated me for doing
what i did if you could say something
to your 12 year old self
or would you tell her
i would say that i'm proud of her
i lost my best friend from suicide when
i was
23
i could do a lot of drugs so i can see
her again and
it was just crazy times after i stepped
in drugs
i kind of forgot about her and i think
that's better for me to forget about her
than actually think about her because
there's no point when she's not even
here anymore
i feel sad for this person that they
feel like they should just forget about
them
that that's going to make it better i
can't imagine just forgetting even the
shirt i'm wearing this is my husband's
shirt i haven't gotten rid of anything
and i don't plan on it you know to
forget anything you know my husband hung
himself
and
to this day like i i it's like a little
almost like a video saved in my mind of
exactly walking in the house i struggled
a lot with seeing him all the time and
that still happens at times you know
i'll be driving and
i'll look you know through my mirror and
look into my back seat
and i see him with a rope around his
neck how i found him
i don't know i wish that i remembered
more of the happy stuff
but
it's
difficult you know it's just like
there
i had a friend
who passed away in the winter of 2018
and on the two-year anniversary
of his death
he
came to me in a dream
and in this dream he gave me a really
really long hug
and then he told me
i know that this isn't okay to ask of
you but
you could always join me here
i'm always so lonely and i told him i
can't because there are too many things
that i have to look forward to
he told me that's okay just promise me
it'll hang out once you get here
and i think about that dream
at least once a week
so i actually have
so many dreams about my friend she
comes to me at least like once a month
but it's the same dream every single
time and i see her and i'm like oh my
god maya like where have you been like i
miss you so much and she's like i've
been in school and she's she's always in
school i mean i graduated college almost
a year ago she would have graduated at
the same time
but she's still in college in my head um
she since she never really graduated i
guess i hope that dream fades for her i
guess
because
i know my husband
is happy for me
of how far i've come it's not been an
easy one since he passed but i know that
he wouldn't want me to join him just yet
i know my husband is somewhere
where his heart
is is at peace and i know he's painting
somewhere listening to music
probably mac demarco or kit cudi having
probably a taco
it's really easy to say it gets better
we need to say that to each other i
think
but it's really hard to believe or to
understand
that it does get better
because people would say that to me all
the time and like you want to slap them
i once woke up in like a pool of my own
blood
i remember being a little upset that i
woke up
but i'm so glad i did
you know
[Music]
you